I believe that if you are pessimistic
and cynical you've already lost if you
decide everything sucks everything sucks
life is very very simple in its complex
infrastructure which is you find what
you're looking for
if you want to be upset about the world
good news turn on the television open
your phone and go on social media and
you will be upset 24 7. on the flip side
if you want to be happy
an optimistic good news turn on the
[__] television and take out your
phone and you could be really optimistic
and happy you're deciding what you're
looking at
not the algorithm
Tick Tock and Facebook isn't [__] you
up you're [__] you up
and so I'm very passionate about that
Dustin can you come up here everyone
this is Dustin Dustin what's up buddy
[Applause]
I'm going to use Dustin to answer this
question
Dustin yes
how long have you worked with me almost
five years
five years ago would you consider
yourself an optimist no what would you
consider yourself I would call myself a
realist but you would say the pessimists
good
do you believe in the last five years
that you've moved
somewhat yes
yes would you say you're as optimistic
as me
would you say you are more optimistic
than you were five years ago
give us something to quantify that by a
number a percent give me something for
the audience eighty percent eighty
percent more optimistic cool thank you
that's awesome but that's kind of
deflating
it's such a natural optimist and I'm not
yes some people are more naturally
gifted some people in this room were
born with a [__] chest it's just the
way it is but can every person make
strides in a direction of being better
at anything the answer is yes I think
it's cool to get better at basketball I
think it's cool to get better at singing
I think it's cool to get better at
skiing I think it's cool to get better
at cooking but all of that [__] is dog
[__] compared to getting better at being
optimistic and happy versus pessimistic
and sad and so watching people like
Dustin watching basically every person
I've been around since I was six years
old if they spend enough time with me or
people that look like me watching
watching my own father be wildly
affected by his 14 16 18 20 year old son
and move from Deep pessimism to a
neutral or 80 better has been one of the
great joys of my life and so what I used
to do for people around me and now I do
at scale
it's very enjoyable it's the best
feeling on Earth nothing feels better
than making someone's life better
there's a million ways to do it but I
believe changing someone's perspective
because it is completely moldable
a perspective is completely moldable
changing someone's perspective to
realizing and it's what he does I can't
believe Dustin went there and he knows
this maybe he subconsciously went there
he knows because he films me a lot like
drock used to people say to me all the
time Gary you don't get it I just keep
it real I'm like real [__] negative
you don't keep it real what's real you
decide shit's broken I decide it's good
who's keeping it real keeping it real is
[__] there's no realism there is no
real
life is how you see it it's too complex
the audacity of a human thinking they've
got it mapped on the record I do not
believe I am right about anything
I believe it's just how I see it
I know one thing I'm 47 and I've dealt
with a ton of [__] through my life and
when I think about my percentage of
happiness and lack of anxiety compared
to the enormous amount of human beings
I've gotten to know in my lifetime I
will take mine every day of the week and
I'm very affected by that especially
when I have real life examples in front
of my face like Dustin and the thousands
of other people that I've interacted
with in my life deeply and the tens of
thousands that I've interacted with if
not hundreds of thousands virtually this
[__] is simple it's black and white we
must fight for happiness
foreign
[Music]